[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello there welcome hello Joey how's it
going it's going okay we are playing
some quick champions we've had this for
a couple weeks now but we are finally it
says right there NDA lifted we can
stream lists so this is the closed beta
of quick champions and apparently there
is an open beta yeah people should be
able to download this to try it out I
guess bring us through a window chat
basically once I haven't played any
quake before okay you know like so
though I'm very new to the whole seer
okay I know of it as a very fast pace
you don't fit everywhere kind of shooter
exactly some pitch for quake is it's
real fast and it's definitely angry
about this one for sure
the only thing is that there are
champions
yeah I think I remember when it was
first revealed that quake was going more
of a audience a little lowbrow Oh
how do we sound now hopefully good
yeah sorry interrupt you that but uh
yeah so the game has champions now which
is a lot of people kind of worried that
it's a overwatch like thing at least in
the traditional like deathmatch mode
it's not really like that it's more just
like slight tweaks to how you want to
play right so Rangers the default guy by
the way in the earlier versions of the
beta all these characters were locked
off and you have to unlock them it seems
in this version they reset everything
which is I only have two but they
unlocked all the characters I think just
to give everyone a chance to play yeah
these character has a active ability
just your alt I guess which is this
board this guy fires I like explode it
and do damage to stuff you also for
passive ability so his passive ability
is a reduced self damage basically he
can rocket jump right anyone anyone can
rocket jump you can still rock a job
because the bunny hop but some will so
be better than exactly there's a this
character right here has a bunny hop yes
so so as opposed to having individual
heroes with very different abilities
everyone kind of has the same skillset
but maybe one or two things to vary
between them yeah it's sort of like
which character fits your slightly
modified play style right I haven't a
chance to play all these characters
dudes and we can do some experimentation
we'll start with the default just Ranger
guy there is customization in this game
there's kind of like the like different
skin yeah full set and then you house
just go individual if you want
there's this whole system where you get
these gems that you so it's weird you
have platinum currency which is the you
pay for it currency you have favor which
is just like the stuff you get over the
course of the game that you can use to
buy new boxes and stuff like that yeah
and then you got these shards which when
you get an item if you have like a spare
item like a spare piece of gear that you
or just one you don't want you can like
break it down to get shards and then use
that to buy to get other okay so you
eventually if you get a set for like a
pair to you don't care about you can
break it down which is cool yeah let's
let's open up this loop box I got here
so there are three types of loot boxes
you got backpacks or standard chests and
I'm happy about relic we reliquary
reliquary premium loot box premium one
that when you can only get through I
believe hang which you can't do right
now by the way open this up see we go
some people are asking where we go no
this is not for ps4 at least right now
right no I don't think they're gonna put
it out on consoles this game moves so
quickly I cannot imagine attempting to
play this game yeah Ian's way that's a
quick start on online start online FPS
says it won't work on console and in his
honest opinions too fast it's too it's
too I think it's too fast
I don't think me those those twitch
mouse skills yeah so we don't really get
much we just got some shader skins
really let's get right into game this
let's play yes we'll start with a good
old when I think a quake I think about I
think of team dev urges regular down
with regular down so we're gonna try
that there are other modes there's so
this team deathmatch there's a dual mode
which I haven't tried yet which is a
one-on-one which I'd probably be
terrible at yeah and then there's
sacrifice which they just added in this
version of the beta so I haven't a
chance to try it out yet and that is
they're pitching that as sort of the
competitive eSports in there they say
it's going to be like the main mode when
they're doing like new sports do and
that's that's the one where maybe the
whole champions thing comes more into
play because it's about team
coordination and like kind of like
working off of each other death matches
I mean you know and even team deathmatch
it's really it's like just kill people
so people like to see exactly by the way
I feel like I should be very upfront
that I am just kind of okay at quick
I've always been kind of okay at quake I
still am kind of okay I will probably
always be kind of okay so keep your
expectations low on my quick miner low
so yeah I'm just waiting for you to
impress me with something yeah
searching so today it's been a little
bit harder to search for a match been
taking longer usually it's been pretty
quick I was able to get matches pretty
quickly this one has been taken
jon-christopher yes I am reading this i
am reading chat yeah if you just joined
us though we are playing quake champions
i will be reading at chat throughout the
whole stream i'm not gonna be able to
read chat i'm playing so if you have any
questions that you want me to relay to
jean-luc just let me know and i'll i'll
ask away
okay we got a match just waiting
everyone queue up other our daily
challenges here assists stuff like that
that you get favor for looks like you
can reload them we got the bench no yep
so far there's only been three maps in
the beta i don't know if they've at it
anymore i don't doesn't seem like it a
Chippewa prince gaming and seven sages
are asking when and where can we get
this is so is it out right now I to the
public I do not know that's a good
question but I do I believe this weekend
they're going to have an open beta but
you should be able to get I just go off
their website you have to download the
Bethesda launcher also it's not all like
Steam or anything no but that it's got
their own little um I'd equate it more
to like a battlenet style launcher yeah
although it's weird like that that
launcher doesn't have like you can't
launch like Skyrim or fallout from it
you can launch the the mod tools for
Skyrim fallout but not like the actual
games proper
we got we got dr. DDoS help okay we're
in reporting like I said I'll mess with
the Ranger you're a bit and then I'll
kind of mess around you can um you can
change characters on the fly any time
well I did yeah if I press fi try this
little orb there stick it'll explode
damage overboard yes that guy is a
hoverboard other characters yes this guy
is like this really beefy dude I've been
messed with a lot of these she's koalas
just messing with her she's got this
song ability where you
Paul is late and
create trail of like poison damage it's
a bit tricky though because when you do
that you can't really like straight you
kind of have to like keep using yeah
romi games forward and it's a little
awkward you need 140 so I guess we'll
try give you the middle finger yep
I'm top of the class real edgy hmm never
Li has that feel
lost every time yeah yeah and you get
back in the real Jessie I can simulate
all that yeah
well I got myself tracked by your best
friend
so is that f ability ability that that's
the the super super yeah so that was her
her trail ability so here's character um
I like her she's the got the lowest
health of everyone
her passive ability yeah just like kind
of neat and then her other ability she
can go invisible and that's not really
invisible it's more like
sorry Helen it's QT nevermind oh I've
never been able to do it before our
ability as rain wolf anywhere before
here like here well if I can reform when
I'm wanted in a guy I explode them but
the thing is is you can't time when -
like reform it just happens on a time
that kind of falls before so the timing
of it is so specific that Nielsen says
no I think people want to see some
Streep jumping oh yeah they want to see
strafe jumping bunny hopping yeah got to
get your you know I'm going because
that's you know I don't play much of any
quake like from what I've always seen
a year game see if I can get into that
zone could be going better
it's like are there any uh platforms em
um yes you can get inside that guy it's
so quick I just feel like it's not even
worth trying to get Andrew bales uh the
open beta is I think going to be open
tomorrow ok ok tomorrow is I'm not sure
I don't know it you want to look that up
actually when I figure it there yeah
right now we are now the closed beta
it's as close right now for me
oh yeah so the open beta will actually
be this weekend whether or not that
means Friday night
we landed that way but I keep an eye out
for if you're looking to quit campus
I'm curious how what the length of this
game will be very for fall we do geez
the games will see pretty hard okay I'm
gonna get him can I get him
once for 13 seconds let's play with a
friend of mine at first he was really
liking it but eventually was just like
man like screw this game because it's
really really a hardcore like some
movement and just like that precision
like if you're good at this game you're
going to slaughter everyone yeah and it
doesn't have that overall appeal
you can just get in you can play a mercy
you'll be fine like there's no there's
no teammates to help you out here yeah
please listen just ya need the sacrifice
mode that's something I want to get into
right Nick
yeah after the NBA did one so we can
show everything yeah
that's like a magic that
not many can get the drop on me yeah I
think for um older fans quake who were
like worried like oh it's gonna come
down or anything like that like nah this
is still justice hardcore feeling as all
the other players which is great for
them I don't know how I think it's gonna
be real off-putting for a lot I don't
know how many let's try and switch up a
character here I'm gonna try
I had this guy's like a spitting I had
intended to kill you last
yeah there you go 115 seconds I think
this is so much in yeah
Lord spawn
it is ahead girl all oh really we go
yeah when I jumped your fall is like
heavier faster so interesting is they're
folding I just seemed like it if it is
pretty I don't really notice anything
oh yeah okay yeah that's just actually
do kill them something like that
Oh
yeah I like I like this game I like the
feel of it a lot it's got that quick
feel yeah the controls are pretty tight
the movements
feels good the frame rate
I'm pointing it at I think the highest
settings right that ever Graham a
venomous from the grave
oh I got from the great strident
character here
it's just messin little let's try this
guy oh is that the hoverboard hoverboard
man so yeah let's see what he's gonna
say yeah they get to choose one of your
default weapon this machine got a nail
gun or a shocker but then there are
better versions this is better
yeah
so that's still definitely important as
a good square items on getting feel like
I gotta find with the rocket launcher
you pick it up you know that's that kind
of stuff is little key to the skate you
it's off already
strongly goop okay ever question or
questions or what type the channels no
no no no weapons I'd like there's no
video
yeah it's like old quake where the
weapons are on the map and you gotta
know where they are
we're jumping in and bad if it just
comes after you need to use a sniper
she's like already bad idea and then the
game is yes make people know how to use
it man who they slaughter okay yeah
funny huh
oh all right well killing my groove man
I'm open for more weird characters
something I was like about quick-quick
Nina was the characters were so weird
and because I'm modders they would add
all sorts of stuff yeah that's the other
thing is I
and I want to see
it's Adam of Goku characters but maybe
like skins or you know tree maps like I
would love the modding community yeah I
think that's a good way to that was my
agility had idea I think that's your
first on earth on your team I believe
well this is deathmatch so it's all Oh
sometime let's see I think a second no
but I get second or third grade step
match I learn a move there maybe I'll
just I got I got fit 15 is okay let's do
a little better earlier let's jump into
sacrifices I've not tried that yet
that's interesting a 92 Crusader says
I'm addicted to this game i've never
played quick in my life until this one
that's awesome I'm like I'm glad there's
certainly like a whole that quake could
fill internode fast speed games that uh
I'm like I'm glad it exists keep her
sane uh-oh I'm sorry I can't really
pronounce game a look over who cathartic
I'm sorry
he says plays visor plays visor oh yeah
I could try my try fine sir so I'll see
you see I leveled up they're all that
really does is get you a new boxes and
there's no like character progression or
anything like that yeah let's see what
survives are all about
she's got like you see through walls and
Farsight he has the ability to strafe
jump let's try it there you go
humility isn't cat meaning he can celery
almost indefinitely okay yeah I think
that's that's what we need yeah let's
try him out also open up this lead box
Alex will Rose yes I believe this is
gonna be only for PC yeah I am NOT a
release it they have not said anything
about consoles and I'd be very surprised
I got Newham shade of room yeah so let's
just put that so yeah you can I could
use this favor here so if I go to yeah
so right now you see it says I own them
all and that's just for the beta but if
you look it says price and it has 500 of
the like you know platinum quick bucks
and then 5000 for favor so yeah so you
could buy it with you yes yeah to 9000
the way it worked earlier was you could
spend your favor to unlock them for like
a day mm-hmm and you'd have like 24
hours to mess with that character and if
you like that character you could then
buy them
it's how they were kind of setting it up
so it seems like they're going sort of
that free-to-play model where it's based
on my characters yeah but as far as like
wanting to try a character you were in
favor pretty quickly at least in the
beta so
you definitely get eight it's not hard
to try new character let's see yeah
let's buy a like nine of these why not
open up no I did
all right knee open some new files I'm
Luke boxy yeah
is this all the champions adjust for the
beta this is all the champions I'm aware
of so far I'm not sure if they're gonna
add any more in the final before the
final release but they'll probably have
ones after that's like I reckon we're
looking uh no that is definitely yes
cyberpunk Rick right there that's the
idea lifted for all content or Oster me
anything anything in the beta we can
show off let's say I got duped there see
they only got five not a loss not armor
shaders share one Q per game yeah it's
kind of game goes look at some of the
other armor
yeah we can't champions right now look
at are you doing the what mode did you
say we're doing sacrifice I believe it's
called which is their their compare
cooperative and that cooperative of like
team-based eSports mode is kind of what
they're pitching at us they said that
any any future like eSports tournaments
are this will be the primary team-based
mode
just lay with the blue hair he's got
that one right in the middle her mix
yeah she's the one who could go
invisible I was showing off earlier I
like her I like her walljump injection
believed you instantly heals himself
receives a permanent boost in his health
also receives his speed boost that's
actually pretty good
and then what the passive one can
control something born they are allowing
to make sharp turns at high speeds
so it's interesting that all of these
passive abilities still require skill on
your end works like you know
yeah if not just press a button totally
it's like you okay people strafe jump
which is useful but you still got to
like be good at strafe jumping right
same like bunnyhopping or you like the
wall job this guys go next OOP got a
match just get in there right and guys
if you're just joining us we are
streaming quick champions it is out for
where the open beta will be out for PC
tomorrow we're in the closed beta right
now which is uh the NDA has lifted so we
can tell you guys all about it alright
and if you want to see more streams like
this you know we'll have more coming up
I think we're gonna be doing one I think
if you want to see us me and John Luke
yeah we're gonna be here every Friday
hopefully that's the plan so every
Friday at 11:00 subscribe to our channel
on YouTube you want to see more of these
streams but yeah get into this okay so I
don't really know how this mode works
it's like a stomp what is the
description for the
hi back look it up now we'll find out
Genji three two one round one part okay
I got a certain soul into it obelisk
shame sports
I did find a flaw records it seems like
some sort of cat was like after the play
some spawned Street jumping
teammate seems just and eNOS yeah that's
dang it all from behind Frank by
wheezing juice
defend point
that hey me because machine is very
hectic I don't know where any mighty
just constantly running
game frontier okay okay
got a guy sir so we got I'm not I'm not
skilled enough to do that okay I give up
- ah so no so I think yes
shams falls like 15 seconds
I think the big guy maybe now that's
some spawn think Oh the the grader was
asking where the quad damage was well
there it was yeah yeah the
on the regular deathmatch it does not
happen work so it seems like Oh
sacrifice opens the maps up a little bit
more maybe that's a shame that's
actually very that actually has been
pretty old-school like unreal with me
bad traffic for today my guys we got
that we need a min shank right man this
is brutal just go with uh no no this
wasn't how I saw this Jewish machine
I'm doing terrible this match by the way
playing his visor we're not serving as a
crime
oh whoops for 15 seconds
oh wait wait one I'm starting to get
angry
I do that so that I really know those
you should have it now I got the quad I
need to like get over there
throws the [ __ ] no
all right oh and I needa lead I'd a
chance to do anything we took at a
potential look at the soil sparse in 15
seconds any other questions in the tap
uh not yet
seems formed
it's like they're asking for some rocket
jump so rock jumps shame
switch to Ranger then
I've always uh
rocket jumps where is the best time yeah
you know maybe that's why I'm just never
been good at quake is because I just
like she had a kinda intuition on
get alerts for simples oh my gosh maybe
we'll use strafe jump as Mike let's get
your clone gotta find another way home
all apps fall protection
attack point food all right ten cloth
says map is much better yeah I feel like
I like this is my like verticality -
yeah I definitely
I'm straining soo
Gally I'm the only one here I'm not
gonna last
oh boy when you've been here this long
do nothing and everything made sense
she knows the Shan Shan that's it yes
the data will be gone tomorrow
right now we are in the closed beta
yeah
Shh all right so now get the hell out of
there swimmer spawns in 15 seconds
school all right got us a point a little
bit closer now nah man you only have a
minute for a rough spot yeah seconds
you see me that yeah that's our best bet
right now in coordination that's what
this modes are about your cheer squad it
says if you stop them if you play as a
ranger you get the ability that lets you
do it to me he's referring to the time
well doing fine so far
snores up great nice fellas machines
Falls in 15 seconds
Oh steak song spawned
rule don't got an already come down to
the wire market is there gonna be over
time hmm
that's a good question feel like it
would happen
now say yeah three true oh it says uh
war [ __ ] when you've grown more round
as a ranger press F again to teleport to
a solution I had no idea that's awesome
thank you round two fight I get the wit
guys both get the point shoes boss in 15
seconds I figured there being overtime
okay we switch sides
some spawned which she has the same yeah
there we go that is people starting to
lead to doors our little guy
buildi though yeah this little timer as
you pick up doesn't need another hero
it needs a lobster which i think is why
just uh um good knowing the maps is
really important if it's knowing like
there's a health there there's the you
know weapon there i can reduce my
cooldown well some spawns in fifteen
seconds
20 bingo literally that's one's fault
okay you know you can use a oh I threw
it you can actually just throw it
Oh real but I press that by circus we
think you can't using your girlie oh
yeah which makes sense especially Oh cuz
like that one girls uh goes walkability
would be like broken if you could use
that hopes phone okay well so far fun
subscription think you'd ever play a
game like this wait I feel I would try
it out I mean it's probably gonna be
free-to-play face on oh really
um I feel like officially sad based on
the way like you know the loot boxes in
the kerosene are schools you know like
trial - you know - like you get that
free like day trial to try the mallet
and pay for them like that's that feels
very much like a deflating I have you
shopping for lunch a few bucks I may
have to also like a with the characters
oh yeah unless they do like free updates
right it's a tricky model I know but if
it is free I feel like that's the best
thing to get people to dislike I'm
willing to try this game out where they
probably otherwise wouldn't if it's like
60 bucks higher go see what you got I
feel like you want me if you spent 60
bucks and you didn't care for it you'd
be real you know real burn yeah
let's a strange take on the flag
oh right into the line of fire you're
gonna mad moneyz down that's because
machine up
in seconds that's all shushing guys
thank you so they announced free-to-play
ish mom-ish ok-ish says you'll get one
character for free and then you can buy
the others or just unlock them gradually
yes yes so it is
then it's based on the way they did it
earlier which is the Ranger will be V
free to play starting character yeah
then everyone else you kind of get to
sample and then if you want to buy them
you buy them three oh damn which I think
it's the right way to go about it I mean
I would certainly not want to buy every
character because there's some
characters I'm like yeah you know
they're just kind of whatever I think
that model makes a lot of sense
some people are claiming it might be
open now Oh on the chat look into that
battle report okay beta let's do another
round of that it sounds pretty pretty
interesting mode
[Music]
by Sandy Fox la mère
all right farmer shade name play alright
got a sick name bankley put that right
there nice different name play oh that's
cooler it's got the eyeball alright
you're ready so hopefully pop this
intersect ace mechs are yes this is only
on PC you see only don't know aegis 421
it's hard safe this is a Oh open beta is
available we're playing on the close
beta right now but as far as far as we
know open beta is going to be this
weekend
some people are claiming that it's
already open and you might be able to
check the Bethesda website if you want
to you know see if you can get a key
right now but it should definitely be
available tomorrow for sure
this is oh more sacrifice yes so this is
this a new map yes this video chain the
third map so we got to see every map
which is good
thank you walking signs are amazing
though I do agree I love the character
designs like me they're all based on old
like quake three models
let's give it a real high risk treatment
gotta grade the caramels and they look
very very like yeah they don't have a
very like if you will get a lot of the
like the Class B shoes now they all have
which i think is the trend right now
yeah so for Quake champions to kind of
go like revert back to that real 9 mins
like yeah hi ray
Dargis you can be sure I'll end it but
you look at um you know this guy he
looks gross
yeah he looks real gross and I love it
it's good I like the character mouth
boiling better I like to see more
remember um we're gonna had a great or
just an eye right true desire to play a
dying around with a girl I think that
orange if I recall it's like an eyeball
dude school lady the light foot matters
some spawn so where is the soul soul
oh they stole it
let's go it shoot
exactly
yeah like I said it's this mode opens up
the maps more I'm kind of curious how
that other map that one's pretty pretty
tight that was open maybe is the name of
the eyeball yes yes and lacy ferret says
the weapons were mounted on his head
right yes oh look this [ __ ] look that up
[ __ ]
it's been forever all I remember is like
an eyeball team scores house remember
all sorts of like now when I played
people are already like real heavily
into like it'd be like you know running
around we're like an M&M and doctor
she's on me I remember around there's a
great mod where young people at adequate
looks to the zone yeah like there's a
modern about it like route is baby look
the hookshot from
great I would search for servers with a
grappling hook
we need a pick it off is the one that
says a lurk but this one is this or is
that is that the name maybe because the
quad buddy what's restless Loy eyeballin
arms yep
good that's board up okay
so they got it
it sounds small so it's big
that is such a nice thing
Oh is spit
she isn't God I think this changes
anything
Oh direct hit she managed to shave
other-centered models until you were
forgiving like the centered the gardens
I think he's might be referring to
centering the gun like having them in
the middle of the screen I'd be kind of
interesting
doom added that in as a gross machine in
like a free update when you call Mia the
center the guns that'd be kind of cool
thing did that here help spawn in 15
seconds
soon swarmed one guy you are never going
to win
power-ups spawned enemy has the
protection Dafydd pointed pen actually I
think the greater I think the rocket
launcher is at least from watching John
we play probably the more powerful
weapons yeah at least the ones that
you've been cheating for uh they might
be referring to um compared to other
Rogers in quake that's always a big
thing about quick fans as which rocket
launcher it's the best Roy a quake
rocket launch reverse the quake teases
quake 3 as far as I definitely play
those games to kind of get a feel for
they're actually in the guns way long
and there is one that makes it look like
one of those are maybe my favorite
cosmetics D I don't know not they're not
helping me out you just know what
honorable means protect point
she's loan help but I like her rec yeah
we didn't do very well
huge kids y2k says you really killed it
in this game mode uh so so Splash Damage
smaller than previous games worked based
on what I remember I change
they're spawning a lot of jump pads out
I definitely like this map in the other
map more than that first one will be
like something happen those for you yeah
as far as lag goes pretty good for the
most part I haven't had like a creme
Joslyn
the servile disservice of all seems
really really good shadows hide me get
him get him it ago
that ever happens that's good
bonus - I know but it's like the
invisible [ __ ] it's got to really try
for it does anything feel like when I do
it though
my god retreat the shotgun sucks put the
ball one oh I won't spawn in 15 seconds
Oh got you from long range
Hinkle is white me with my team
power-ups spawned point
some sparse 15 seconds protection seems
swarmed
oh my god we got it we got the soul
now they are fake Street jumping yes you
on the chatter seriously they want to
see they wanted they want to see high
quality
oh never intended me that it's in
coordination to say everyone we need
alike get over there we did it yeah
fairly everyone at once
exactly it's cannonball some small
suburbs
oh I'm just in there basil thank you one
here power should not be in this game
um I don't line them but she school I'd
be interested to see if they added a
mode that just like removed hero powers
but then at that point the problem is
that Karen still have like you know
armor and like differences
you have to like make a mode where it's
like every character has the same health
yeah at that point it's just skins right
like you'd have to Adam please remove
all differences between the characters a
rope suave they've teeth said that there
is Benjamin which is a long so I wonder
if that that means like the health of
everything yeah they might have to
change that I did have to oh well that's
just go know that they're adding that
come on
for once maybe where you can assure all
these it's what I like kill him
so yeah I was out there to retire
damn almost be sacrificed
yes it's very I agree spoo we did
terrible bad time so Assoc they do not
like the default announcer voice and
it's the quake3 announcer yeah the quick
three announcer has the cheesy charms
yeah sure
um this guy's okay it doesn't it doesn't
stand out to me though give a favorite
multiplayer announcer that's a good
question
I think I like smashes announcer smash
is a good one yeah
free-for-all I like always like the halo
announcer and I like how they've had him
forever game and I feel like I remember
four and five he got like way more like
campy with it where he'd be like Slater
and you're like yeah I'm into this
yeah chat if you guys got like a
favorite announcer for any game not just
quake I don't want me to try this dude
try them out we could try a cyberpunk
Rick uh yeah let's do second Fresno more
time
just a new mode I feel like it's the
more interesting thing we're brawling I
do this one more uh one more game Oh
actually before we do let's show off
show off the different gun customization
that's that's pretty cool yeah so it's
the quake 3 machine gun super shotgun
it's this is the supposed to be a skull
shock and originally said doom shotgun
but it's not really like that's also not
really a dude shotgun so I think that
maybe that's why they change that chain
gun does have any a quick for lightning
gun which is cool a quick run there it
is just a quick one rocket launcher
rendered in glorious high resolution
than the equate to railgun it was like
people like the halo announcer
yeah these are definitely the most
pricey things to guys the weapon the
weapon skins and near vin says fable one
has a good narrator oh that counts um
table one but table - I like a really
famous like British celebrity forget who
may I think it a little big planet
remember little Bo that a little big
plane like Stephen Fry or something like
that
you listen announcer there yeah he was
like the narrator something like that I
don't know maybe it wasn't Stephen Fry
[Music]
please learn to strafe jump this is
awful to watch you can move four times
speed WTF I mean yeah you're not here
yeah you're wrong is there a quick three
rocket launcher no nose the skin it
doesn't seem like they'll probably add
more of that stuff I bet ya strafe and
rocket jump will get the full quake
experience all rockets all the time yeah
what fun uh custom matches yeah all
rockets triple speed you know good goofy
stuff like that someone says Nick Cage
was the best announcer in what I want to
know that he well he would be he would
that's true oh you know it's actually
pretty good I think it's uh I think it's
black ops one uh like ice ice cube is an
announcer Ice Cube I think it was ice
cubes because he I believe I believe it
was Ice Cube but I believe it was it was
like a DLC pack or so no because he did
a voice of a character in that game and
so they had him play the I think the
better player now say I believe it was
that there reminds me of like when they
when they add a GPS or voices like
celebrity voices - GPS navigation that
like game download Snoop Dogg and have
it be on your Garmin or whatever oh um I
don't play it but dota 2 has a ton of
really fine and that's right you can
download announcer packs yeah you can
get the bastion narrator which is good
you can get a Rick and Morty this one is
pretty good
yeah beryllium Johnson smash is probably
my favorite schnauzer it's good one he's
really enthusiastic yes I like I like
narrators are announces that are really
enthusiastic and really really cheesy
about it but not like cheesy in a bad
way has to be like Nona fun always liked
self-aware yeah like that the old life
you know more good for even for you
imagine more you this was good we can
answer don't diss me man
oh so my problem with strafe jumping is
that I just do not I feel like I have
the tactical ability to like me with any
like because you do you're right you do
move like four times speed but then it's
like I start moving like like I can't
like it it shuffling and I think that's
just my own skill or lack thereof she's
gonna go try to get me out hope you hope
you enjoy it yeah yeah your team Rome
artists renounce their master to get to
one row one point okay get that soul
people some scrolls in 15 subs
apparently there's a Windows updates
ignore it play through it draaga that's
all
six out Xinhua and Freddie
good announcer to write our dark oh yeah
battle could be mostly enthusiastic
German man I'm in bad I remember uh I
want to say game was and there's a game
that I remember was gonna like allow you
to make your own basically you can make
your own stuff mature which is the new
version of Unreal Tournament which I
don't know if they've ever actually done
anything with that outside of Prague
okay
that game has like a perpetual beta you
can download yeah but I want to say they
had a finger I was like oh you can sell
your own patch so you can sell your own
weapons you can sell you on skins yeah I
think you could at least I can announce
the shade we can like because you can
make your own and I thought I'd use of
the fun way I wouldn't do it but just
the idea of getting you guys have a walk
born in 15 seconds yeah [ __ ] with them
oh my god Jameis gazers voice gotta find
another way
James ratings rise to be good no rocks
form 26 we got it Catina songs Falls 15
seconds your channels of the dirt trail
band eating your teen for the Soul
all right another here shame spawn
getting that soul in there and practice
your speech jump yeah practice
ah have any weapons though how big is
the beta so the betas got four modes
deathmatch Team Deathmatch this mode
which is called sacrifice and a dual
mode which we haven't tried and I will
be terrible at so we will not drive and
then it's got three max you in this
version of the beta you get access to
all the characters from the get-go which
is pretty rad
other versions did not stable kinda like
testing so yeah I think it's a decent
amount means there's a lot of your team
believe it goes all the way tobe 21st
cleavers swing you small kids so don't
put our time to delve 0:09 we are
reading from both YouTube and twitch
chats so yes I can probably I can see
yours and I can also see it everyone who
comes on YouTube as well --shoes spawn
that's all in there man
instantly how many gigs my king knows if
I pick someone earlier at 10 yes mole oh
maybe I want to say was like 13 for me I
came in their bags for Joseph III was
fondling hey this is technically my bass
is what it is
mmm cuz it there I think you have to put
the soul in the other person's bass I
don't know how her shoes did you bring
back to yours guess our last one at the
optimist cave sacrificed
cool all right run 19.2 gigs and return
to gigs in yeah that sounds right so
this is guys trash wrong not wrong for
it's a language of me that would be
first in swing goes I I do not know but
as far as the game goes the games ready
Wallace
there's no lag in the game yeah haven't
seen any like stuttering or nappy maybe
like one heat up but that's soon spawned
they got the full that person at the
sole sometimes the world doesn't need
another view it needs a monster I think
those which are the overwatch right
there
soon so I didn't even think of bad
okay so what's the key egg-wich Ovilus
because it said I could choose which one
I wanted the treasure
yeah I didn't think of that but that
probably totally is a that's pretty good
back to Luke says you know 1v1 jerseys
page at the morning with four with quake
yeah is how do you all want you he's
always asking me to what you want even
overwatch
I will not know an easy one in Quail
lose I'll lose at anybody 1v1 quake some
sports in 15 seconds
I love quake but I'm terrible at I
established this upfront everyone I'll
rip spawn in 15 seconds
rocket launcher on this swing spawned
one thing that teleports it's real
disorienting if you don't really have a
oh I was trying to like throw it but
never was machine oh they got it though
wrist Craig I got is a quake champions
beta keys so hope you enjoyed game yeah
yeah man enjoy
we're going to be popping off in the
sack after the silver
sorry they just not gonna attack us well
okay I'll tack me oh there's only one
person on their team oh that explains so
much she lost 15 seconds I'm aware of
oh well that's gotta blame now I feel
bad she still killed also she's killing
me all the time it's amazing I feel too
badly not that bad some spawn that
explains why we're winning
Miriam you tried the gauntlet yet no I
have not
I'm not even sure what that is I was the
one boy the mood a rough spawn and
people in serves all right now isn't a
whole weapon maybe might be a weapon
pose weapon like literally a obelisk Age
sacrificed we everyone well I think
that's gonna do it at this point
uh-oh the melee weapon the godless of
Mahler won't yes yes the main weapons
pretty good you just like this buzzsaw
okay so did you use it all now it's some
mates one of those things it's like
pretty like last-ditch effort yeah
so yeah that was quick champions thank
you everyone for tuning in and checking
out the game thank you for putting up
with my subpar quake your non Strief
jumping my mommy's don't being rocket
jumping quick abilities you know I think
I'm honestly I think I'm okay this game
and I like I like just me no cannon yeah
this game is going to be available
tomorrow for everyone to check out so
you know if this is something you're
interested in um yeah go go play some
quake everyone quake is back you can
play it look at that guy is so dumb
yeah so um again hope you guys enjoyed
watching if you want to see more live
streams like later on possibly next week
I think we're gonna be doing a bunch I'm
not sure when will stream quick again
but when we do you should will be able
to but find someone better find some
better to play yeah so you know
subscribe to our channel on YouTube
twitch check out all the features we
have on penis watch calm Devon we'll see
you guys next time
yep see you
[Music]
you